[Music]  oh can i try no no no no no i i can't  let you jump off here daddy  he won't let me jump moon come on let  her do the thing yay what's your weight  [Music]  all right let's get you down rosita oh  my gosh you guys this is exactly like  the dream i had last night  seriously you  you were all there and you and you and  that funny-looking guy over there  all of you  and you asked me to sing for you  i  i did yeah and so i was like  this girl is  [Music]  [Music]  well that's a  lovely dream you had there portia  i have climbed  the highest mountains  i have run  through the fields  only to be  with you  only to be with you  but i still  haven't found  what i'm looking for  but i  still haven't found  what i'm looking for  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  dream big trees we just gotta be brave  now wrong again  again  you will never be great johnny  what i'm looking for  [Applause]  i'm looking for  [Music]  you